the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
get started so alright cool so ok so
before I get into any hands before I get
to any hands I wanted to sort of talk
about tournament services cash games
since I haven't really made the
distinction yet so essentially ok so
this is a big chart with all the
differences so when you guys play in the
things online those are called
tournaments so in the tournament you
sort of buy in for a fixed amount of
play chips in this case it's not that
relevant it's like one player dollars
and then you get for coming in the top
20% around you're gonna get some out of
play chips paid o2 and like if you win
you get the most and if you just barely
make it you'll probably make fact like
to play chips so you'll profit one place
ship or something so that's all
tournaments work and that's sort of what
throughout this class so far I've sort
of assumed all that all the hands are
taking from tournaments so there is a
different way to play poker and a lot of
you might have actually been introduced
to coker like this you know so you have
like sort of a home game where there's
just a bunch of friends you're playing
at someone's house and you all buy in
for some amount of play chips and
basically you can play and you can
people can join and stop anytime they
can if you lose all your play chips you
can just buy in form or you don't it's
not like tournaments where once you're
out you're eliminated and you can never
go back into that tournament and cash
games you can buy and whenever you know
you can like hit and run people you can
come try to make a bit of money and then
just leave as soon as you make a bit so
it's ok so what what are the main
differences so I sort of want to be
highlight the differences between the
two types of games and talk about why we
mostly choose tournaments in this class
so ok so everyone knows the definition
of like what what a
is what a cash game is so okay so let me
talk a bit more about so what are some
differences so when cash games usually
the stakes are fixed so usually you know
ll say we're playing for like one one to
one play doll or to play dollars or
something like that whereas in
tournaments I'm sure if you've noticed
the lines keep going up right the blinds
start 10 20 in your tournaments and then
they become 20 40 and then like 40 80 or
30 60 I think there's actually there's a
15 30 level I think so it's 15 30 and
then 20 40 and then 25 50 and and it
keeps going up right so and the reason
this is the case is so that eventually
the tournament ends is that the blinds
don't go up the tournament will take
forever to end all right so what's a big
factor about tournament sources cash
gains isn't in tournaments you have no
control over your table you just join
the tournament and you put out some
table and you just got to do or best at
the table you replace that and the fact
that there's not this much as metagaming
I think is one of the reasons it's much
easier to analyze poker hands and in
terms of tournaments using cash games
you know if you're at the cash game and
everyone's really really good you could
just choose I don't want to play in this
cash game anymore I'm just losing my
money and you could choose to stand up
on leave and there's a lot of decisions
of this form so and so it's it's there's
a more meta gaming required and in
tournaments the general goal is to
survive right you're just trying to get
eliminated as late as possible to
maximize your payout whereas in cash
games a lot of it comes down to you know
if there's one bad player at the table
you're trying to target that specific
player you're trying to do everything
you can to get in hands against that
player and exploit them and win a lot of
money against them and brisk a lot and
stuff like that so and yeah so there's
less focus on the massive poker and more
focus on specifically targeting certain
players tournaments there's frequent but
fixed losses so you know so if we were
playing terms for real money how it
works is you know most of the time right
like 80 percent of players get paid
anything back from the tournament so
when you play tournaments most of the
time you're gonna lose even if you're
really good you're not going to win more
than 50 percent of the time so you're
gonna lose lose
lose lose and then you're gonna get a
big win and it went a lot and then it's
gonna be lose lose lose lose and you're
gonna win a lot right sort of like
playing the lottery where as cash games
anything can happen you can lose a lot
if you're having a bad day and you
decide not to quit you could lose all
your money buy back and lose our money
buy back in eventually lose all the
money in your bank account right that
should happen you can also win a lot so
anything can happen but in some sense
tournaments is more variance so like
when I was talking in the first class
about the law of large numbers and
reaching the long run it does overall in
some sense that they longer if you're
playing tournaments because in
tournaments it's you do need to
apparently get the big score in the
tournament it's like sort of like
winning a lottery to to make back all
your money and if you don't then you
won't make back all your money yeah I
argue that tournaments I think are more
fun there's the more exciting if you
make it far in a tournament you know
eventually it comes down to just two of
you is pretty exciting
also tournaments have a wider range of
situations so in cash things you know
usually it'll be a fixed number of
players at the table and players will
have a similar number of big blinds
because whenever you lose a bunch of big
blinds you can always just buy back in
and get those big blinds back by putting
more money on the table
whereas in tournaments we have to learn
how to handle I think interesting
mathematical situations where you have
like one big blind
how do I play it optimally and stuff
like that the last thing is if you play
the casino though another good thing
about tournaments is relatively the
casino makes a lot less from tournaments
and cash games cash games just as a
fraction of how much money you wager
there the casino takes way more compared
to tournaments I'm tournaments what the
casino what the house takes is very
small okay so so those are sort of the
main differences but I did want to sort
of comprehensively go through the
differences because you know if you do
decide to play poker these are the two
essentially the two ways to play it so I
wanted to make sure everyone was well
aware of these differences so yeah so
why I chose tournaments for the class I
think it's there's less metagaming I
think it's more exciting I'm mostly a
tournament play
myself other had played cash for cash
games for extended periods during the
career yeah there's a wider range of
scenarios and I think it's more
applicable I think you know like the MIT
poker club the event of running in
January is a tournament because
tournaments are exciting okay so are
there any questions about this chart
okay cool okay so yeah so our club
actually has both I mean for the points
these tournaments count but if you look
at this this thing above then I
shouldn't say no all right the drawing
here okay so yeah if you if you look
there then these are the cash tables and
you could in theory sit down there and
play for the play money and if you do
lose all your play money in those cash
tables to a sharp in the class and you
have no more play money and you can't
join tournaments you can always refill
your play money and join the Germans so
that's why it's called play money okay
so but yeah only tournaments count for
standings and if you want to see the
standings you have to you have to oh I
see the annotate so so you see that you
got to click the blue arrow and then you
can see the standing some people asked
me about this so if you want to see your
standing some of these everyone has how
many points you have you can click to
that you can put there okay all right so
let's get into some poke your hands now
you know that being said I highly did
all these differences about cash games
and tournaments but good poker is
essentially good focused like if you're
good at one you're probably good at the
other the difference is still rather
small it's more based on like you know
how much risk you I want to take what
kind of scheduler do a lot of play on
that determines which one you choose to
play rather than like am I better than
tournaments or cash games like at least
one source except at the very top levels
there you know
really is no difference between like
there's no such thing as a casting
specialist except at the very very top
where it's possible you're the best cash
game players are are good at cash games
compared to the best tournament players
but like when you're just starting out
if you're good at one you're good at the
others essentially all right cool
so so today I'm going to talk about some
preflop play so last class I focus on
post law flight the first class I talked
a bit about what hands you should open
with preflop but I didn't really say
that much about playing pretty fun but
it's sort of the most one of the most
important parts are the hand cuz it
determines what cards are playing for
the rest of the hand so okay so first of
all I wanted to run through sort of some
numbers it's good to have a sense of
these you don't have to memorize all of
these but it's good to have a reasonable
idea of equities of specific hands
versus specific hands when you get it
all in pretty far so and I sort of
classified this to make this roughly
easier to memorize so okay so the
biggest example so the first example
which is sort of the dream situation is
you have a bigger pair against a smaller
pair right what's the best situation
that you can be given preflop in poker
if so what's the best hand you can have
it's aces right but you don't want a
system for everyone else you had three
to offsuit because they're just gonna
fold right so you want ace is and you
want someone else to have Kings one of
my screen names is actually uh please
give me a say-so against King King or
something on the site because it really
is the best situation you can hope for
because they're gonna put all their
money in with Kings and you're so
roughly when you have a bigger pair
against a smaller pair you're an 8020
favorite so you win four-fifths of the
time and edged windle's a bit as you get
to like three three versus two two
because there's a higher chance folks
pairs will be counterfeited like the
board can come six six seven seven eight
or something and then in pocket three is
theis pocket deuces okay and an equally
good situation is one pair against zero
over cards so eighty States against Ace
King off is that so a very good
situation you're actually 93% there
because you dominate the race so there's
very few ways for them to win pocket
aces against six five suited this is
actually the hand that's best against
aces other than aces itself it's six
five suited and that's each this is only
seventy seven point five percent but
it's still you know ludicrous
so pocket jacks against 10902 eighty one
point seven percent so some rough
numbers you know ten nine suited is
pretty good but pocket jacks sort of
crushes it because having two jacks
blocks a lot of their straight outs
pocket queens against seven four off is
very good because seven four off is not
suited not connected and the best you
can do preflop is actually King King
versus came to off yeah if you have
pocket kings against King deuce off I
think I think that's the highest equity
you can possibly get it in preflop is
94.6% and pocket kings against kha
suited is eighty nine points so look how
much better king two suited does again
then came two off against King King the
fact that you it's easier to make it
flush it's so relevant we'll talk more
about this later okay the next few
categories so one pair against a pair
against one over card so you're still a
favorite but less big of a favorite
instead of an 80/20 or a 70/30
so Queen Queen against ace jack-off it
is seventy one point seven percent Queen
Queen against ace Jack suited is a bit
worse Queen Queen against ace Queen
suited is actually much worse than Queen
Queen against East Jack suited I think
this is a bit counterintuitive at least
because so with against ace Jack suited
I always thought you know they have more
outs they can hit three jacks but it
actually turns out the fact that they
have a clean to prevent you from hitting
three of a kind in this situation
they've already hit an ace it's actually
a lot more relevant so so so yeah so
Queens is much worse against Queen than
this Jack and yeah pocket eights against
h2 off seventy seventy point two percent
pocket threes against h2 off is a bit
worse because once again small pairs can
get counter
when you go on preflop okay a similarly
good situation which is the 70/30 is
when you're dominating the other person
so dominating means one of your cards is
the same but the other card is different
and yours is higher
okay so ace king off against each queen
suited pretty good situation to get in
in poker your seventy or 70% if you're
suited and they're not then your 75% if
neither of you are suited at 74%
yeah ace king off versus came clean off
your you're actually a bit better even
though King so ace king off against ace
Queen off your 74.4% tasting off versus
King clean off your 74.8% and you're a
bit better because because it's harder
to tie with the ace so when you both
have an ace it's possible the board will
come with two pairs and then so like six
six seven seven eight and then both of
you will have two pairs of sixes and
sevens with the ace kicker but that's
less likely to happen if they don't have
like if your bottom card is their top
card instead of your top card being
their top turn one thing to keep in mind
is ace 5 off against h2 off is barely a
favorite at all so it's nowhere near as
your this ace Queen off against ace
jack-off anyone have an idea why that is
right exactly so you so the five and two
are gonna get counterfeited the the five
kicker is gonna get counterfeited a lot
more often because if four cards on the
board come that's higher than five the
five is gonna be irrelevant so so yeah
that's a good thing to remember all
right so like let's look at some more
numbers okay this is something that I've
always had is really cool to over cards
versus a pair is actually very close to
a 50/50 for the most part Ace King
suited against pocket twos is 49.9%
I actually showed you in the first class
if if they don't have a two of your soup
and it's actually like 50.1% so East
King off vs. pocket twos is 47.4% note
that ten nine suited against went
against pocket choose is actually a
54% favorite it's much better than ace
king against pocket twos because 10 nine
can make a lot more straights and
flushes and the fact that you know
you're making a pair of tens instead of
a pair of aces isn't that relevant is
irrelevant when the thing you're trying
to be is a pair of deuces Ace King
offers his pocket queens is only four to
three percent even though people call it
a coin flip it's actually much worse
than a coin flip
so yeah this is actually one of the
things that first things that drew me
behold and when I found this out I was
curious you know did I was wondering the
person who invented the rules of Hold'em
did they invent it so this is a 50-50 or
that it was just by coincidence that
it's about a 50-50 but I think it's very
cool that it turns out to be a 50/50
okay so okay so the last case is you
know there's some weird cases where all
four cards are different roughly
speaking when all four cards are
different the guy with the highest card
is going to be a 60/40 I mean this is
very rough because it's hard to
encompass all the different types of
scenarios under the same umbrella but
roughly the thing that matters is having
the highest cards so okay so let's say
so a B versus C D which means you have
two cards above they're two coats you
know you can be as good as 67.7% if it's
like Ace King off versus Queen seven off
because Queen seminoff has no straight
outs and no flush outs
yeah AC versus baby it's about 60 versus
forty ad versus BC it can be as low as
50/50 so East - off against ten nine -
there's only 51.6% so that's sort of the
worst case for for high it for like a B
versus BC okay so you can look through
those numbers or on the slides and you
can you can also get it yourself on
poker so over a lot of websites you can
compute the equities of a hand versus
another but it's good to have some rough
ideas of these categories you know one
isn't an 8020 one am i a forty one favor
one am i seventy three favorite one am i
a 50 51 a - 6040 okay so one thing that
I hope you sort of got from these
numbers is that suited this matters a
lot when you're behind
and matters not that much when you're
ahead so if you look at these numbers
the gain and equity of Ace King suited
when Ace King started the gain of equity
of Ace King when Ace King suited is only
1% you only increase your equity from
seventy four point four to seventy five
point four but if a screen is suited
then the equity of Ace King drops by
four percent instead of one person right
and the reason essentially is if your
hand is bad you need as many ways as
possible to try to get lucky and being
suited as one of them but if your hand
is already very good you just really
need your opponent you not get lucky and
you're being suited it's only gonna be
relevant if they first you know they
first hit a pair to beat you and then
you need to hit a flush two to beat them
so that's one thing to keep in mind so
like with Ace King the defensive ain't
suited and unsuited it doesn't matter
that much but with a hand like nine
eight being suited is way better than
being not suited and studentís is also
important for implied odds as I talked
about last class because you can make
much better decision to little swap if
your hand is suited okay so so okay yes
so that's the roughly some hang-up
woodies do remember okay so now we're
going to talk about some preflop all
ends so going all-in preflop so okay so
this class most of this class okay this
is gonna be a bit boring maybe these are
not really highlight reel plays and you
know this is about like routine making
good decisions that increase your
preflop equity by a couple percent that
will but it's really these boring
decisions I think that make your winrate
not the occasional brilliant thing that
you see on TV so you know so if your
goal is to get on TV then studying this
is maybe pointless but if your goal is
to you know make expectancy win money
essentially then it's really the simple
boring decisions that affect whether you
win not the one time crazy Bluff he
pulled off against Phil Ivey that makes
you the winner so okay so okay so let's
talk about this a bit so so the main
thing is one thing is don't be afraid to
go on preflop I mean I didn't really
stress this yet but one thing I tend to
see
will do is you're too afraid to put all
your money in preflop because you would
think it's gambling or something or it's
like you know it's it is a lot of luck I
mean you know you essentially put your
tournament life you let it ride on a
coin flip so it does seem scary but the
things to remember essentially is when
late in the tournament the antes and
blinds are so big and if you ever can
swing the blinds by going on that's such
a large game relative to what your risk
and also just any two cards of a chance
against any other two preflop so what
was the rule I said so the rule I said
in the first class is when the effective
stack size is less than twelve big
blinds when there's antes then just go
all and if you're going to play the hand
at all and if there's no antes then you
need to be a bit you need to be a bit
shorter because you don't want to risk
twelve big blinds when there's no antes
so you only want to risk like ten big
blinds without antes but this is the
rule that I outlined in the first class
roughly and when you can go on and one
thing I wanted to talk about - before we
get to the first example is this from
the small blind so in the first class I
said your button opening range is
similar to your small blind opening
range and why was this even though from
the small blind right so what's when
it's folded - to you in the small blind
you may have to get through one more
player whereas when it's folded you're
on the button you need to get through
two more players so it seems like you
could play a lot more hands from the
small blind and another advantage of
playing from the small blind is you've
already put in half a blind so the
amount you're going to put in DML and
more you got to put in to play the part
is less is half blind less but we said
that being in position right especially
we saw this last box being in position
is so important that the fact that
you're in position on the button and not
in position on the small blind meant
about balanced out the advantages of
playing hands from this small boy so we
said you know roughly speaking you
should be similarly willing to put too
hands from the button and rate raise
hands from the small blind but for all
ends position doesn't matter right if
all the money goes in the pot preflop
then who gets to act last post doesn't
matter because there's no more actions
to make post law so for all ends your
slugline all in range can be a lot
lighter than your button all in range
and furthermore I think the threshold
with how many bets you can have to go
all-in is a lot higher because even with
like 15 even with 20 big blinds I often
go all-in from the small blind if I know
the big blinds a competent player
because from the button I would pretty
much very barely go on for 20 big blinds
because I'm not that sad if I just raise
it to 2.25 and then call because I get
to played the rest of the hand in
position but from the small blind when I
know that if they call and playing the
hand out of position I really want to
avoid this situation so going all-in for
a huge amount from the small blind is
usually ok since there's only one player
behind anyway okay so so okay so let's
look at a sample situation and I'm going
to first analyze it theoretically and
then I'll try to go through a bunch of
the examples so okay so do we go all-in
or fold here and let's suppose we're
reasoning exploitative right so this was
level 2 thinking not level 3 thinking so
if we're reasoning exploitative ly what
we're asking ourselves is essentially
right what's exploitative thinking we
put our opponent we model our opponent
give them a probability distribution and
then play in a way that maximizes our
expectation relative to the Bayesian
probability distribution we put on our
opponent so you know we can ask yourself
is the big blind a gambling player is it
likely he or she will call with a wide
range of hands how crazy have I been
playing you know will he give me any
credit if I go on
suppose the pay paid bubble doesn't
matter so suppose it's far from you know
having to try to survive to make the
next pay increase or whatever so okay so
let's know so let's do this what do we
think he's calling okay so this is okay
so I want to see what the
you guys think so does someone wanna
give me a hand that you think he's
calling or definitely calling or
definitely not calling you can give me a
no-brainer I just want people do
someone's attack okay so what's the hand
he's obviously not calling okay to
seminar see what's the hand who's
obviously calling okay so let's try to
zero in a bit more okay so let's okay
don't don't worry it's okay so tell me
what hands do you think he might be
calling better a bit worse than
populations like okay what do you think
he is the smallest pocket parity song or
what okay let's if you're not sure let
me ask you what's the smallest pocket
pair you would call if you don't know
anything about in this small blind so
it's 15 big blinds it's a 15 big blinds
fall okay he would call pocket fives
okay he would call call pocket cheese
okay he would call a seven suited okay
he would call a queen Jack offsuit okay
okay so okay so I guess we have a rough
idea of okay so since assuming you're
playing at someone in this class so
let's just say we look at that sample
just sort of guess what they're calling
so okay so I had this range maybe it's a
bit and more ambitious than what people
put up their hands for so I said they
would call with any pocket pair any ace
king 10 off suit king 8 suited so this
is what I said they would call with it's
just 25% of hands okay so maybe in
reality they call with even less maybe
in reality they only call 20% 15% of
hands but but this just further
emphasizes my point so okay so so you
assume they call it 25% of let's say
okay so let's do the math let's now
assume we have ten eight offsuit okay so
let's do the math against this oh sorry
so what is the equity of 10 eight off
suit against their 25% range so when we
get called we're not doing so well
because there
calling 25% of hands so their hands
gonna be good when they call more than
36% okay so let's do the math so 75% of
the time they're gonna fold and we're
gonna win 2.5 big blinds right why is it
2.5 big blinds it's it's there's there's
a big blind that we're winning right
there's a small blowing that we're
winning and then there's there's a one
big blank than the antes that we're
winning right and it's 3.5 we count the
small blind because even though we put
in the small blind the fact that you put
it in the pot that it doesn't matter who
put it in the pot the fact that it's
already in the pot means we're winning
the money okay that makes sense okay so
25 percent of time he's gonna call and
then when this happens 36 percent of the
time we're gonna win the online and
we're gonna win sixteen point five big
blinds because we're gonna win the one
point five we're gonna win the small
blind the antes plus is entire 15 big
blinds back sixty four percent of time
we're gonna lose and we're going to lose
working and a half big Lines's which is
how much we wagered to do this on so you
can do the calculation and/or it's
actually very positive we're making an
expectation an entire big blind by going
all-in okay so now let's suppose we had
a worst hand so let's suppose we had
three two offsuit okay we can do the
same calculation again the only thing
that changed is now we only have twenty
eight percent equity instead of 36
percent equity so vichu offsuit is
actually a worst hand than 70 offsuit
for a lot of all-in purposes because 70
offsuit is like the worst poker hand
against a range of strong hands but
against a range of any two cards to
reach you off is actually worse than 70
off because seven high is relevant if
they have like six high okay so the
anyway so you so you do the calculation
and you find that this is still an
excellent play yes
so going on with three two offsuit
there's actually not a crazy bad play it
looks like a crazy bad play on paper and
okay and I'll tell you in reality it is
a crazy bad play but but according to
this calculation it's actually not a
crazy bad you
you're actually earning 0.42 big blinds
okay so what's wrong what's wrong why is
why does our calculation say 3-2 off is
a good play and there's no mistake in
the calculation it's not because of a
mistake in my calculations right exactly
okay good yeah so basically remember we
did this calculation using level 2
reasoning exploitative thinking right we
built a model for him and if our model
is correct then actually 3g officer is
good all in but so so what this is
showing us is actually the point is if
our model was correct then they're
making a mistake he's making a mistake
by only calling 25% of hands it's just
too small a fraction it's true for too
small a fraction of hands to call so I
guess the lessons sort of is you know so
you said when I took the poll around the
class you guys want you to call even
less than 25% right like 25% still
includes a stew offsuit and still
includes hands like let's see again it's
no includes hands like Queen King 10 off
suit Queen ten suited King eight suited
so so you know so even 25% is sort of
too low in the sense that it allows a
small blind to shove any two cards chub
means on shove any two cards profitably
and in reality it might be even lower if
people were being truthful and they put
up their hand for what they're calling
with right so so basically my point is I
think people are too afraid to go all-in
preflop going on preflop is it's fine
basically and you know so what suppose
we're the big blind now and we're
considering adding queen jack off to our
calling range so you know so I'm saying
okay you're making the mistake as a big
blind of only calling 25% but but what's
wrong with my reasoning right the thing
that's wrong with my reasoning is that's
only a mistake from a level-3 reasoning
point of view right that's only a
mistake in that it's not theoretically
optimal because in theory the small
blind could show the any chip cards
profitably but if the small blind isn't
actually
new cards then maybe this is actually
the optimal range to call like if the
small line is shoving too small then
maybe 25% is the optimal strategy for
the big blind from that point of view
so right so we can do a calculation with
Queen Jack so let's assume the small
line only shoves top 25% of hands
instead of a hundred percent then your
equity is only 42 percent and what do we
need to call and we need to call 14 big
blinds right we need to call 14 big
lines and if we call the pot will be 31
so we need 14 over 31 which is a 45
percent equity we only have 42 so we
actually shouldn't call any more so you
know it's possible the big blinds play
is correct but the point is someone's
play isn't correct so so I also wanted
this example to give you another idea of
what sort of optimal Nash equilibrium
plays so okay so I'm gonna sort of so
let's draw a chart of what is in game
theory called like an iterative best
response okay so how this works is I fix
the tragedy for one player I take the
best strategy for the other player at
exploiting the strategy and then I fix
that strategy and I come back to so I
fix a strategy for the big blind which
is only called 25% of hands and then I
ask myself what's the best way for the
small blind you exploit this well it's
to shove a hundred percent pains right
okay so now if the small blind is fixed
on this strategy what's the best way for
the big blind to exploit this well it's
to call with anything basically because
you know they're shoving anything so
what's the call at the very wide range
say like 67% of hands and you know so
what's the big big blind is calling too
much how does the small blind exploit
this well now they tighten up right they
only shove their good hands and that's
fine because they're getting paid off
very often when they shove their good
hands but once the small blind realizes
to shove only their good hands then the
big blinds like oh crap I shouldn't be
calling 67% anymore
I'm gonna call less 30% so overall let
me draw sort of a diagram of how it's
gonna work so okay so you can see right
0 100 small blind okay
so essentially how it works is okay so
let me just put some markers okay so how
it's gonna start up is the big blind
calls 25% right which is here
25% and then the small blind to exploit
this Jones a hundred percent then the
big blind goes to call 67% and then the
small blind will respond by shoving 40%
these numbers are approximate right then
the small blind will shove too little
and then the big blind was sort of call
too little and then it'll essentially go
here and then go here and then go here
and then go here okay so essentially the
point is it's gonna converge it's gonna
zero in on this blue line okay on these
blue lines and the thing that zeroes in
on is basically called what's called the
Nash equilibrium so you can actually
compute the Nash equilibrium with a
computer in this case which is what I
did and this is what the Nash
equilibrium is so the the optimal thing
to do is for the small blondish of 66.8%
of hands and the big blind to call about
38.5% of hands so and i think if you
play like you know reasonably like
reasonable stakes online poker
tournaments nowadays this is what most
people know how to do because most
people will have a computer program that
can do this calculation for them but
it's quite loose essentially for so
remember the situation was 15 big blinds
there are auntie's and you're in the
small blind you should be shoving 2/3 of
hands gruffly and the big blind should
be calling almost 40% of hands and this
is this is the ranges and as you can see
the small blind can chug for three
student so sue the nurse is very
important but if your hand is unsuited
then seven six off suit as a shove but
oh six five off suit is a shove - but
like nine five off suit is not a show
because it says nine six off Plus which
means nine five office
not so okay so it's so it's always a
good idea to know the national Ange is
for preflop because even if you're
trying to exploit your opponent you want
to make sure you're never going too far
off from the off you play because
whenever you get too far off you could
potentially be getting exploited and so
yeah but I mean you don't have to do
exactly this I'm not saying everyone
should do exactly this right if you
think you're smarter than your opponent
and they have a good model of the near
opponent like if you think the big blind
is calling way fewer than thirty eight
four point five percent of pans then you
can go in with a lot more than sixty six
point eight percent of yes just make
sure if you do decide to try to exploit
your opponent you do the exploitation in
the right direction
unlike if they're calling too little
then you need to shove a lot if they're
calling too much then you need to shove
very little that makes sense every with
to everyone right that's the that's the
right direction to exploit your opponent
and similarly if the opponent is shoving
too much then you're gonna call a lot
and if there's something too little than
you then you call very little as well
okay but yeah but what's good about the
Nash equilibrium strategy is you know
you can't be exploited you know no
matter what they do the optimal
basically the reason why this is this is
called the convergence point is because
if the small line is shoving 66.8% the
best for the big line to do against that
is 38.5%
and the best to shove against 38.5%
calling range is six to six point eight
so it essentially converges if that's
why it's called an equilibrium so so
hopefully this gives you a better more
concrete example for those of you who
haven't seen like what a Nash
equilibrium is exactly of what I mean by
like optimal level three reasoning play
okay so that's enough of that okay so
now let's go do some concrete ranges so
okay so now you can ask me you know how
do we learn these ranges right I showed
you the Nash maing for one specific
situation but right situations you can
you can enumerate there's gonna be a lot
right so I showed you the range for
small blind versus big blind and there's
15 big blinds right but what if it's 14
big blinds what if it's 13 big blinds
right what if it's 10 big lines of no
aunty
so essentially it's a combination of
memorization understanding theory and
then like extrapolation / interpolation
so okay so let me just show you a few
more we can just so just to give you a
rough idea this is where the
memorization / interpolation comes in
because if you have a few baselines to
go off of you can sort of so you can
sort of use rules that theoretically
make sense to extrapolate right so
here's button ten baselines 43.9% and
this is roughly the hands oh sorry this
isn't clear what this range of Hanson's
means I guess I never really explained
basically like s means suited Oh beans
off suit and plus just means any hand
that we're like the denominations are
circling higher if you don't know
exactly what it means it's not a huge
deal but roughly but roughly you you
want to sort of know what this is like
what this is saying so there's a few
weird cases but roughly you know if it
says ace x plus that means any ace any
hand with an ace suited or unsuited you
can use it along so okay so 43.9% okay
so right so in terms of extrapolation
and interpolation let's just make sure
everyone gets the directions right so if
I move from button to the cutoff does
the proof there's a fraction of hands to
upward down down right so the traction
hands goes down because from the cutoff
there's more players to get through
right so you you need a better hand you
can't write so the fraction of hands you
can shove those down right that makes
sense everybody so make sure you get the
direction right so okay and then what if
the number of big lines goes up or down
so let's say it's let's say it's 15 big
blinds
I guess 15 is sort of too much to go all
in with but let's say it's okay let's
say it's 12 big blinds does someone have
a guess what the percentage might be you
just have to get the direction right
what something yeah
yeah okay 40% that's about right that's
about right basically so I go egg the
percentage will go down a bit and what
if you only have five big blinds does
someone want to say it gets the
percentage 60 yeah that's about right
okay so yeah so try to get the shot at
the directions right if you have a few
baseline points and if you and if you
can get the directions right that's a
very important first step okay so here's
another data point I cut off seven big
blinds
it's 38.8% so notice that the cut off
this situation compared to the first one
your one position worse because they're
cut off into the button but you're
risking a lot less you only have seven
big blinds
but the percentage is still going down
so I think I said this first class as
well the position matters a lot more
than the number of big blinds because
for the number of big blinds even though
you're in some sense risking a lot more
as you have more big blinds it's also
harder to get called if I go all-in for
10 big blinds they're gonna fold a lot
more then if I go all-in for seven big
blinds so that's why the position
actually matters a lot more than how
many bets
okay so LoJack that's that's hijacked
minus one so that's two over from the
cutoff it's only twenty eight ten big
blinds is only 23.4% but it's not
nothing
not nothing so under the gun nine handed
with three big blinds it's actually
pretty high it's 24.1% okay so you can
go look at those on your own you can
also calculate on your own in certain
websites and yeah so this will roughly
give you an idea of the shape of the
graph so this is under the gun Islands
it's a bit approximated but with 15 big
blinds I know I recommended a 15 big
blinds not to go all-in and I think
that's a good recommendation but let's
say you told the computer they were
forced to go all in with 15 big blinds
and they have to calculate the Nash
equilibrium this is what it would spit
out it would say you go on with this 6.2
percent and with 10 big blinds it's
thirteen point four with five big blinds
it's thirty three point three so it
actually increases quite a lot for for
under the gun for under the gun the
amount of
the fraction of hands you can wager as a
function of how many big blinds actually
goes up quite a lot question yeah for
example here we have 15 big blanks as oh
I would read to like two big lines or
2.25 for all hands I essentially raised
a 2.25 big please close from two point
two five big bites to all it right yes
no little rage right right there's no in
between yes so the reason essentially is
okay so let's say you raise to 5 big
blinds right this is essentially
equivalent to an all and except and
worse so why is it equivalent to an all
in it because if your opponent has
pocket aces or like a good hand not
necessarily pocket aces they're gonna go
all in and pretty much you have you have
to call I mean okay if you knew they
have exactly pocket aces you could fine
but it's possible for them to play a
balanced strategy where they could have
pocket aces or ace king or pocket pens
or whatever and you're forced to call
anyway so essentially if you make it any
more than 2.25 big blinds you put in
enough chips that your opponent can just
play a strategy that forces you to go
all-in when they want to and so it's
basically certainly worse than just
going on yourself yeah maybe yeah good
question but but yeah we're 15 big
blinds I would recommend just raising
small although I don't think going all
and it's the end of the world
yeah ok so this is roughly what the
shape of the curve looks like so here's
another example so for a hijack from 15
big blinds to ten big blinds it actually
changes very little I guess it changes
somewhat about twenty three point four
percent to twenty eight percent and then
with five big blinds that goes up very
fast so as the number of big blinds goes
down it increases a lot but the
difference but the change from 15 to 10
isn't that much I guess under the guy
that's a lot but for hijack it's not
that much so just give you just give you
some ideas you know I don't expect I'm
going to do
perfectly I'm trying I gave you a bit of
data points just try your best to do
extrapolate a lot take that you try your
best to extrapolate slash into your
blade you know if you if you're off by a
lot that's fine the biggest thing is
just try not to get the direction wrong
you know they don't think if I have if I
one position worse I can shove more
hands or something
so okay a few more pointers about going
on pretty fought so here this is
definitely a good play I think so you
have pocket floors from hijack you have
15 big blinds which is more than what I
said you should go all-in with but I
think but going on is a good play
instead of just raising two to two times
the big blind because small pairs while
having good implied odds when when very
deep so in the last class I talked about
set mining I said small pairs are great
when you have like a hundred big blinds
because you can try to hit three of a
kind and just win a massive amount of
money when you do but they actually have
terrible implied odds when it's like 20
big blinds deep because because you only
hit three of a kind 1/8 of the time when
you do the total effective sack size is
not enough for you to recoup your losses
and when you don't you're just always
really sitting there with a pair of
fours and there's always going to be
higher cards on the board it's gonna be
like ace jack 10 and you're always
playing a guessing game does my opponent
have a better pair and you just can't
make good decisions so so that's why
with small with small pairs just going
all I need them for a lot of big blinds
is reasonable so here's another example
Queen eight so good you normally you
wouldn't go all-in with that you
normally would just fold under the gun
if you had a lot of chips but with only
five big blinds going all-in is fine
another factor that's actually sort of
relevant here is this is sort of a
higher level thing but it's good to keep
in mind is when you're under the gun in
some sense you have the least to lose by
busting the tournament so by going on
you're risking busting the tournament
but so this is not sure in a cash game
but in a tournament it's true I was you
want to go all-in from under the gun
when you're really really short you have
very little lose to lose by betting the
tournament because if you don't bust the
tournament
the next hander you're the big blind
which really really sucks so even though
you busted the tournament you've busted
the tournament in a situation where the
next hand you would have had to pay the
blind which is one fifth that you're
stacking misses so going on is okay
each tier suited is another example the
hand that's pretty good to go all-in
with because if they have a better ace
you're still suited so you have chances
of catching up and the fact that you
remove an ace like there's less aces out
there for them to have is is quite
relevant actually the fact that there's
three aces out there for them to make a
good hand to call you with and then
being four I really know what I mean by
that so if you have a nice there's one
less ace out there to go around yeah so
we go I'll go all in here okay and yeah
here we have seventeen and a half big
wines from the button but I think going
all in with ace four off is fine
basically so it's a lot it's 17 and a 17
and a half big blinds but once again
each X off suit is has terrible and
Finance it also like protects your small
pair shoves a bit so so you know when I
said this pocket choose hand there
started this pocket fours hand I said
you can go all in for 15 big blinds but
what's one problem if you follow the
strategy exactly it's whenever you do
this your opponent knows you have like
pocket twos or pocket threes right then
you're like what can they do they can
like call with ten nine suited which is
not a good hand like ten high against
the 15 big blinds up shouldn't be
possible but they can so if you also do
this with like a sex it protects
protects you a bit yeah with seven six -
did I think it's also okay this is a
similar story pocket deuces seven six
suited has great implied odds when
you're like a hundred that's deep and
making straights and flushes is very
relevant but when you're only 20 bets
deep and you're just trying to make a
big pair essentially small cards just
aren't good at making baked pears
you can't make big pears so once again
going on is acceptable okay so oh yeah
one day you watch out for
is I actually suck this under the rug
and the last couple of slides but in all
these cases I showed you there's
actually a pretty big disincentive to go
all in there's anyone see what it is but
by looking at the stack sizes so so
they've always been the same actually
but there's someone say yeah pretty big
disincentive right although actually I
should say this other people having much
larger section II was actually an
incentive to go all in the reason being
it's it's possible like let's say you go
all-in and then someone calls and then
another guy like re-raises on and the
first guy who called folded then what
would happen is you're still all in and
if you win the pot and you know triple
up instead of double up and you still
only have to beat one hand did that make
sense everyone I can draw it out if it
didn't make sense so like so you you go
on 450 400 so let's see this guy cause
450 400 this guy calls 450 400 and then
let's say this guy goes on for 12,000
and then this guy falls which you
shouldn't be doing because he definitely
has ought to call but let's say he does
fold then the situation is great because
how the rules work is now the pot so now
she this guy is going to get back 6600
and the pot but but 5,400 of his is
still in the middle and essentially
there's this 5,400 this 5,400 and or
5,400 and you're only against his hand
and if you wait and get all the money so
so you actually triple up into the
double so that's actually a good
incentive but yeah that's a good
observation yeah so yeah that is really
yea so multiple people can call but the
Nash Manges that I presented do take
that into account so like the National
Ainge is the Nash calculations you
taking account that multiple
you have to look carefully at the stock
sizes uh yeah right good good
and then I wish about one of those gift
certificates okay I still have some bite
okay
so right so this is actually very
relevant and I soaked this under the rug
but let me play the annotation there's a
big blind only has four bats only has
four big blinds in this situation and
they're basically guaranteed to call you
know that's not a terrible result for
you because there's a good chance they
just have absolutely trash in Queen
seven suit it is better than them but
it's still worse than being able to
steal the big blind for free so the fact
that the big blind is so short here that
they're basically almost guaranteed to
call maybe they'll fold like three to
offsuit it's really really bad for you
because your chances of just winning
down the taking down the blinds without
having to win an all-in is a lot lower
that make sense to everyone so so it's
hard to do when you're just starting out
but it's good to pay attention to all
the different sack sizes and if there's
someone behind like someone in the
blinds who's very short and here's
almost guaranteed to go on then you
should be a lot less incentivized to try
to steal the blinds
alright guys
alright so okay so I'm gonna give you a
few more gonna give you a few more
examples of sort of extrapolation I know
this is a bit boring but to be honest I
think you know this is less exciting
than you know playing post flop and
reading your opponent and trying to like
read what cards they have and trying to
make tricky Bluffs but really in
tournaments the best skill you can have
when just learning just starting out is
knowing when to go all-in because if you
you know even if you're pretty good at
it
versus very good at it the fact that
because most hands just come down to
going all-in preflop if you're gonna
increase your like equity every time you
do this violet even 1% that's a huge you
know that's a huge game
terms of how profitable the player
you'll be so so yeah it's a bit boring
but you just try to bear with me this is
the most important skill in tournaments
essentially okay so I wrote down on this
graph
sort of the most number of big blinds
and willing to risk all in front for it
all and four from each position so I
want to sort of illustrate a concept
these numbers are actually quite
ambitious by the way I think I made this
maybe four years ago when I was trying
to play exploitative Lee against the
fact that the average player was too
tight the average player was not willing
to call often enough so you would be
able to shove more hands than Nash
because most players don't call enough
nowadays I think people are getting
closer to Nash
so you can't really do this ambitious
anymore like all these numbers should go
down a bit you shouldn't be doing all
under to have any better but nonetheless
the graphs illustrate the same point so
I've roughly personal I broke down black
how many bets I'm willing to risk from
each position with ace for offsuit so
notice that from the button that's huge
it's 22 but under the gun is a lot
smaller it's only 7 and roughly roughly
it decreases as like as like a 1 over X
skirt as like a inverse rule and that's
sort of intuitive because you know if
you show from the button you need to be
like the best out of 33 hands so it's
like well number 3 and then you're going
to be the best out of 4 so it's equal
number 4 and then 105 1 / 6 etc so so
the graph is roughly I mean I don't know
let's say 88 over number of hands remain
something like that but okay but I want
to show you a similar curve with 7 6
suited some K what do you notice about
these two curves right so this this one
is very curved this one is like 1 over X
I mean this one is maybe there's like a
this one it's a lot flatter right it's
9.5 under the gun which is more than 7.7
for ace 4 but a slore it's a slore it's
it's
22 from the bottom words for 76 it's
only 19 so the thing is these dude hands
are a bit different so with essentially
with ace 4 off the it's actually like
it's a hand that does poorly against
good hands but well against bad hands
because against a bad hand your ace high
is gonna be good and again it's a good
hand you're always gonna be dominated
like if they call with a nice jack or
like a pair of sevens you're gonna be a
30/70 right where is it 76 even if they
come aces you're it's I mean it's bad
but they're like it's the best hand
against Asus but basically 7-6 you're
gonna be better on average you know if
they call with ace king it's not a good
situation but it's much better than if
you had these four where is you where is
um if they have like 8 to offsuit which
is a terrible hand that actually
theoretically is ahead of yours so
what's the most important thing about
760 than going on with it
essentially it's having a lot of chips
it's having a lot of sack because you
just really want to you you want them to
fold all their trash hands and it's good
when they're not gonna call you very
often so you want to have a lot of bets
whereas for ace for the most important
thing is you know you don't mind they
call as long as they call it a bad hand
so the most important thing you want
with ace 4 is you want to have you want
to be later in position so that you're
against fewer hands so that there's a
less of a chance that someone behind is
gonna pick up ace jack or pocket tens so
when you're extrapolating slash
interpolating try to remember this
principle so yeah so with like a suited
connect your hand it matters a lot more
how many bets you have you wear is with
with like a hand with two unsuited but
sort of big cards like ace for offsuit
King eight offsuit Queen I guess Queen
seven officers or whatever the thing
that matters most is having food players
left you asked behind okay okay so I
talked a lot about how do you initiate
islands from preflop so what about
calling other people's all ends
so okay so yeah so one other so another
thing that I suddenly see people do is
fold with ridiculously good odds preflop
and similarly how you can shove any two
cards food cloth you can also call a lot
preflop because you'll always have some
equity so yeah it's difficult to have
less than 30% equity preflop no matter
what your cards are unless your opponent
is like has a really strong range like
they're really tight and you know they
have like jacks plus an ace king or
something
if difficult they have less than 30%
actually if you have an ace in your hand
right because I because if you have an
ace then you're either gonna have an
over card at least to their pair or be
dominated but both of those are still 30
70s only if they have aces are you
actually in really bad situation so okay
so I just wanted to show you a hand here
that looks maybe a bit like bad play do
something but I think it's very
reasonable reasonable play so okay so we
have 98 suited we have 15 big blinds so
we don't go all-in
right which is fine we make it 1,600 and
then it's folded to the big blind but
the big blind goes all-in for 10 big
ones if our certificate em big blinds so
you know so normally if the big blind
had covered us if they had 15 big blinds
you would probably fold this because you
have nine high you probably you don't
have enough odds to call but in this
specific case the effective sack size is
not 15 big blinds right they only have
10 big blinds so the effective sack size
is 10 big blinds so if you do the math
when the effective sack says there's
only 10 big blinds you basically you
have enough equity to call like even if
they had 12 big wines maybe it's very
borderline but even if they have 12 big
blinds roughly speaking you have enough
equity to call right this is sort of the
same calculation as me saying if you
have 12 or less big blinds and you raise
and someone goes all-in
you basically have to call this is sort
of a similar calculation it's the same
thing you raise someone went on and if
it's effectively 12 big blinds and you
can call so this is a totally reasonable
play and then you just call okay
if you do the math you need 37% equity
to call it's possible in some like
corner cases you can convince yourself
that you don't have 37 percent equity
but for the most part I see a lot more
like bigger mistakes by people holding
this spot like if you call your number
really making a huge mistake okay fine
if they're like sort of tight maybe you
only had 35 percent equity and you and
you need to 37 you made a small mistake
but there are situations similar to this
where you might have like 45 percent
equity and you only need 37 percent
equity so it's a huge mistake folding
can be a big mistake for calling Israel
look like a huge mistake when it's 12
big blinds or less so yeah so any hand
that we would raise here in the first
place we probably would have enough
equity to call like you know if I had 72
offsuit here I probably would not call
but I would not raise here with 7 GRC so
any hand that you would have chosen to
open here which is about like 30% of
hands are 25% of hands yeah I think you
can call ok here's another situation
that we sort of talked about already you
have four big blinds and you have to pay
a big point basically you pretty much
have to play close to any two cards in
this spot um if you do the calculation
right you only need to call
I mean calling is equivalent to going
all-in sort of like if you go all and
you know you're getting called because
they're gonna have they're gonna have
almost 41 odds which is so they're gonna
call so essentially the calculation is
do I want to wager my entire stack on
this hand and you're risking three big
blinds for a total pot of nine and a
half big blinds
so essentially you only need thirty
percent equity to call and thirty
percent equity is very easy to have
preflop essentially so yeah so basically
I have to play any two cards Queen eight
off is way more than good enough yeah so
this is basically the calculation I just
went through and yeah like here I think
I would probably play 95 percent of
hands
I think I'll fold like three to offsuit
for two off suit but I'll probably play
any
with a card that's like 10 or higher and
I'll probably play every suited hand
okay so let's talk a bit about rebasing
all in preflop now so and all the
situations I showed you were just about
going all-in and someone calling preflop
so yeah so okay so I wanted to show you
know so don't do this don't call free
pop I already talked about this but
especially when you have ten big blinds
don't so once again here don't just
raise when you only have ten big blinds
if that's less than twelve so you can go
on yeah so you basically either want to
go all-in or full so but I want to sort
talk about raising now so okay so why is
this so bad but this is okay when we
have more big blinds so now we have
everyone has everyone has 1999 a
half-baked points so why is this okay
the main reason is because so in the
first case right so I talked about this
if you get caught if someone goes all-in
you basically you have to call anyway so
you might as well go all in yourself
because you're not getting away if they
pick up a good hand so that's the same
calculation okay I'm just gonna skip
that pair that it's the same calculation
essentially it's just saying there's
there's no point to not go all-in
because if someone else goes on we're
going to we're essentially roped into
calling anyway so the second case we can
get out we can pull okay so let's keep
this in mind right so in this case we
can definitely fold so so we can do the
calculation in this case we need to call
17 big blinds to win a total pot of 40.5
we need 42 percent equity and we almost
certainly don't have this because we
raise the early position they went
all-in against it early position raise
so they probably have a good hand we're
almost certainly gonna be a 30/70 okay
so yes and so let's look at whether we
call or be raised so for rear a size
okay so now let's put ourselves in his
shoes if he's rebasing sort of the same
principles apply when you're rebasing
so the advantage of rear easing to a
small size is
you know what if it's deep enough where
he could be raised and we could we could
like for bet go we raise again and go
all in then they could fold that they
were intending to do that advantage of
rebasing to a large size is you deny
your opponent Dodds to call profitably
and once again if you if you're really
sighs would cause you to commit a
critical portion of your snack such that
you can't escape you're gonna go all in
anyway then you might as well just
rebates online so it's essentially the
same principles but let's see this in
action so so you say yeah let's so this
is what you don't want to do and I see
some players doing this which is fine
because I've never really explained this
in class but if someone raises let's say
2000 you don't really want to just click
the raise button this is what would
happen if you click the raise button
because he raised 1200 from 800 to 2000
so if you click the raise button this is
the minimum that you can raise it to
2,000 plus 500 but if you look at the
odds are giving him it's actually
ludicrous right they have to call 1200
so they have to call 1200 and the pot
will be the pot will be 550 264
essentially 7,200 so yeah so it's 61
right they got a call 1200 and do a pot
of 7,200 so this size is basically way
too small so how big do you want to make
it roughly speaking you want to make it
2.5 times they're open I think that's a
reasonable rule if there's a lot of
factors that can affect this but if
you're not sure what to do a reasonable
rule for pretty amazing preflop is 2.5
times what the original vibrates if
you're out of position you might want to
raise a bit more because there's more
incentive than to call they can play in
position post flop but but I think in
this specific spot this 5,000 is a good
size okay I'm going to skip this slide
so but in this case actually so can we
see our stack size okay so our stack
size is only is only 20,000 so in this
case I think going on it's a bit big so
you know so
the thing is if you're gonna re-raise
it's the same principle again where if
you're if the amount you'll be raised to
is sort of like more than a quarter of
your stack which sort of means you are
sort of committed and you can't escape
then you might as well just go all in
your cell
so I'd say in this hand if you had like
less than eighteen thousand I would I
would just go all-in because you can't
really escape even in this specific case
where you have twenty thousand I don't
think it's terrible to just go all in
instead of making it only five thousand
because it's pretty hard before the hand
as good as ace king even if you make it
five thousand and then he goes on for
twenty thousand so but I think twenty
thousand is enough that you can make it
five thousand and you know you can do
this with your good hands you can also
do this with your bad hands sometimes as
a bluff to balance it out and you can
fold we do have a bluff and he goes
all-in
so so yeah that's roughly the sizing you
want to make it pretty fun and okay and
another thing I want to say is why is
calling a preflop raise okay so so I
said in the first class if no one has
entered the pot and you're just
attacking the blinds you always want to
raise you always want to raise to give
yourself a chance to win the blinds for
free you don't want the blinds to be
able to see the flop for free but if
someone has already raised I think it's
okay to call I mean the handling Ace
King is sort of too good but if you had
East Jackson did or ace Queen suited I
think like just calling is fine so why
is this so it's because the reason why
in the first case you there's no real
advantage to not raising like just
calling is because the big blind if they
big blind has a good hand they can still
raise anyway so it doesn't matter but in
this case there is a huge incentive to
not rebase right what is the huge
incentive here it's so let me go back
here
what's a huge incentive to just call for
two thousand instead of making five
thousand is if you make five thousand if
you make it five thousand then you give
him the option to go all-in right this
is a huge difference and in the case are
you're just raising the big blind they
can't go all-in
but here you're giving him an
so that's all you just want to call some
time so that they can't have the option
of going on okay
so this is a good example so it's so
this is now a different scenario but
it's very deep the blinds are only 25 15
players have like 8,000 which is I guess
160 big blinds and here calling is
definitely a positive expectancy play
because you're in position it's very
very deep there's a lot of money still
to play for an imposition for all the
rest of the hand which is great this is
a good play so if you raised in this
spot it could lead to disaster right so
what happens here is you raise and then
now hijack -1 the guy who originally
raised may not have an option to rebase
again which is what they do and now it's
just terrible we basically have to fold
we could call if we're feeling lucky but
we basically have to fold and I mean I
think calling is actually in reality a
reasonable but basically it's a much
worse situation than this one where we
just called so that's a demonstration so
if someone's already raised you can just
call I'm gonna talk more about this next
class as well like a preflop strategy
against someone who's already raised but
that's one thing to keep in mind another
thing I want to go through quickly is
how to deal with colors so I've said
that you should never be just calling a
pot when the pot hasn't been raised but
people will inevitably make this mistake
and usually if someone you know if it's
full to do someone no one's empty of the
pot yet and someone just calls we call
the term in poker is a limper which is a
bit of a derogatory term poker actually
has a lot of derogatory terms which is a
bit unfortunate but I sort of have the
tough decision that you know either use
making up my own terminology but then if
you like going to the poker rule no one
understands what you're saying or I use
the same terminology which is derogatory
but okay so what are some common
Lumpur's either way so you need to be
prepared and raise their lumps but you
do need to change you're a size of their
numbers so so let's say normally when
it's deep you decide you base
three big blinds which is which is fine
I mean I said raised it to 0.25 but I
think it's fine if you raise to 3 it
doesn't matter that much when it's deep
like you can raise you three to play
bigger pots but if there's a lot of
bloopers ahead then you want to make it
more than three because you're because
there's already money in the pot so if
you only raise it to three you're
actually giving them two good abodes to
call so let's say in this case I only
make it three if I only make it 150 then
you know by the time it's full to do the
last guy their odds of calling are gonna
be they have to put in a hundred into a
pot of 375 right so that's like 3.75
DeWine odds that's too good so roughly
the odds the rule is take whatever size
you were going to raise to and then add
a big blind for each lumper this
essentially makes it so that the odds
are the same as before so in this case
if you were gonna make it free I make it
three plus one plus one plus one because
there's three holders okay and of course
like you know if you only have 15 big
blinds then in this case and said
amazing after six big blinds you might
as well just go all-in right the fact
that you only raised to six big blinds
instead of going on in is predicated on
you having at least like 25 to start the
hand or something where it's enough to
escape if if they go if something weird
happens after okay
I'm gonna finish off sort of showing you
some more simple preflop situations I
think so with the theme of this class is
sort of you know being boring I'm sorry
about this like so being boring being
simple just playing on simple
probabilities and using calculators is
you know can get you very far in poker
and you know I will go through you know
crazy Bluffs and exciting hand reeds and
stuff like that as well but this class I
don't wanted to stress the simple things
that I think are good um so okay so so
you know here this is situation so here
you have four three student I'm you're
you're too scared to go all-in can I
raise due to big blinds them as an
alternative oh so you're the button okay
so the button only has eight big blinds
they started the hammock
and they they make it 400 with only 400
behind so I want to show you why this
can go wrong okay why is it bad if you
don't follow the all anymore all because
now let's say the big blind has four
three suited well if you went all in for
a big wines they'd have to fold their
four high but yeah I'm not going to run
through the calculation again but the
problem is now if you only make it to
big wine so you can actually call your
small raise at four three suited and
they have four point five to one odds
and that's definitely good enough odds
for so so essentially um so if our hand
has forty percent equity against his
rage range then it's gonna be plus C V
so essentially they're gonna call and
they're not gonna raise the 4-3 suit so
basically they get so the fact that we
didn't go all in gives them an option
here with their good hands they can go
all in and rope us into getting all in
anyway
one board the button when with their
backhand it's like four three suited
that they don't want to go all in with
they can still call and see a flop but
the point is we're essentially so yeah
this is eventually the strategy you can
beat it I'm not gonna read through the
site now but the point is we're giving
them an opportunity to make a better
play than the otherwise could've if we
just went all-in
the choice is theirs they are their call
or they fold but here they essentially
they can take their best hands they want
to get it on with and go all-in and we
call or with their with their worst
hands like for three suited that can
still call you see a flop they can call
and see a fob and we're just letting
them realize a lot more equity than we
need to so you know so okay let's say
okay fine if you want to get around that
you can make it eight hundred and you
know if we made it eight hundred its
it's more or less equivalent so if they
were gonna fold them they were still
gonna fold if they were gonna rebate on
then we're still gonna call and then you
know it's mostly equivalent I'd say in
this exact situation making it if you
raise you eight hundred it's pretty much
the same as making at sixteen hundred
but on some off chance it's still
possible you were giving them free
option like you know like maybe they're
better
with four three suited is still to just
call and then if the flop comes really
really bad for them like a Stace King
maybe that's not even that bad bit like
just nine eight seven or something I
don't know um they could they may be
full so basically I think just keeping
it simple is good and so one okay so one
concept I'll finish on is there's this
idea of okay so I have talked about you
know all this stuff I'm saying as a
letting them go all giving them the
option is bad but you know what if you
think they're so stupid
that if you give them the extra option
they're actually going to make a mistake
and and giving them strictly fewer
options is actually is actually bad you
actually just want to give them more
options even though it's free options
because they might make a mistake so
okay so this is slicing you from from a
while ago but bill Chen sort of gave a
very good kinetic example of this but so
bill Chen he actually might give a guest
lecture the last lecture we haven't
decided yet but he might come and speak
just for the last lecture of the class
this year he she wrote the book called
the mathematics of poker he's one of the
like world experts on sort of the math
behind poker
he's a like he's a math PhD he's
currently a trader at Susquehanna
International Group anyways so you say
oh this is what bill cheng calls a
sucker bet and sort of when when you see
your opponent do this you should almost
be a bit offended like I sometimes this
occasionally like very rarely happens
but when it does happen like I'm
sometimes very confused because my
opponent shouldn't be doing this
so maybe they're they're stupid and you
know they didn't go on because they're
stupid and
every option but maybe I'm actually the
stupid one maybe they think I'm so
stupid that if they gave me the free
option I'm gonna make a mistake
so you know so like if you do get in a
situation like this it's it's actually
sort of an interesting theoretical
question I think like if you're sitting
in exactly big blinds shoes you know you
saw like let's say you know the button
is a confident player - this makes it
worse right if you know the button is a
competent player then you're saying yes
this sort of this sort of reveals what
they think of me if they're giving me a
free option to see the flop here with
four three suited they must think I'm
gonna mess it up so bad that they'd
rather give me the screen option than
not but yeah but it's an interesting
concept to think about and sometimes it
does happen another sort of example of a
sucker bet is I guess I was talking
about last class on the flop or even on
the turn or whatever you never really
wanted like that a very small fraction
of the pot like if the pot is a hundred
and then your opponent checks you and
you bet a dollar and do a hundred you
know it's not a real bet it's $1 into
100 it's essentially an epsilon bet it's
essentially a zero bet but what does it
do it gives your opponent a free option
right now they can check raise you like
if they now it's saying okay I bet a
dollar now you have a second chance to
bet on the flop right you check the flop
but I'm gonna bet a dollar and do a
hundred and now if you want to make it
fifty you can be even rebase my $1 bet
to 50 and now if you want you can and if
you think your opponent's gonna make a
mistake you can try to do this it is it
is a very specific exploitative strategy
but it's interesting in that it's so
obvious as an exploitative strategy so
anyways okay I think it's I think it's
an interesting theoretical thing okay
yeah so I guess okay so I think what a
few more examples so once again you know
these are all simple hands but I just
wanted to show you I just wanted to show
you there's the only way you can mess up
this hand is by not going all in you
only have 15 big blinds someone's
already raised a lot you know you don't
really want to try to do something cute
like slow playing especially you know if
you had aces maybe so Plains okay but
with just East King any hand is so much
a booty against you
and you know you just want to go all and
here's an example where is someone
someone in the lake position raises and
you have a pocket pair you can go all in
and this is pretty good because we do
pretty well against their range that
calls you yeah so so this is this is a
pretty good play often I'll talk more
about this in future classes but if
you're defending your blinds often with
small pairs rebasing all in even if it's
for a lot of bets is a reasonable play
because you get a hand they might have
been folding pocket three spots for us I
think it's it's quite likely um I think
yeah I think the Nash equilibrium is to
fold pocket threes pocket fours if you
have enough chairs but one that you call
you even if they have a hand like a king
you still have fifty percent equity
right so small pairs are pretty good at
just re raising all and against late
position steels yeah so all in here is
good and yeah so if it's the last
example is also easy it's essentially
saying so under the gun raises hijack -1
calls you have a great hand on the
button and only 20 big blinds you know
you just go all-in
there's no reason to be cute and make it
like 8000 I like I guess unless you were
trying to sucker your opponent and yeah
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna stop here and
then so next class I'm gonna maybe I'll
maybe run through a criminal history
next class like I'll show you guys a
history of me playing a tournament and
try to discuss some of the decisions
that'll be one of the next and extra
classes all right cool thank you